oh my gosh wow hey y'all welcome back to
the corridor cast you may be wondering
where jake is well jake is a smart man
so he's not here because yeah we're
doing something a little different today
we are doing the howl and raise heat
challenge all right and each of us here
today is going to take one bite of these
little death sticks
these are these are chicken tenders that
are coated with some of the hottest uh
hell dust hell dust is perfect
i've ever seen and yeah for for you
video watchers
this is a oh dark don't
demented
[ __ ]
you won't do it if you smell it that
someone has
people have eaten this before you guys
this one's the someone else is eating
besides darker we all go dark side it's
you know what we're all talking brave
right now and i'll say this was this
felt like a really good idea when we
were talking about it upstairs yeah
you know you got to take it from the fat
side this today i was like super excited
for it and now that i'm here i am
terrified yeah my stomach hurts just
thinking about it i can smell the heat
from here guys i'm scared i can
literally smell how hot it is i was
supposed to do yoga after work today i
don't think i think that sounds like a
terrible idea
we're going to be pooping on the five
that's if it makes it out the other end
okay look good let's let's just let me
just say right now this is not a let's
freak out and go nuts over spicy food
nope podcast no it's a we're going to do
a normal podcast yeah so let's not
freaking dance or beat around the bush
here dance around the grave or whatever
i did let's just do it listen i prefer
we have some two percent some oat milk
and some capri suns okay yeah yeah
russian's getting in on this tube oh and
by the way yeah if you're if you're a
real one you're not gonna do any of that
stuff
kind of set himself up here he said he's
gonna finish the whole tender he's gonna
only drink beer which is acidic which
will be worse than nothing yeah and
you've kind of committed to that you're
going through something at home and you
want to just feel something yeah i don't
want to feel anything oh god all right
well this will help all right i'm only
doing the tip yeah we take a bite and
then we just go on with the podcast
y'all yeah i'm gonna do it we just have
a nice do a huge like cheers i don't
want to do this cheers cheers i can't i
can't reach
all right oh
no
oh hold on what
oh
right
it's so good
okay no it doesn't we did it i think
what we should talk about is some of the
movies we've seen recently there's a lot
of good stuff in theaters
our r is an experience that i just
recently saw
and it was one of the most spectacular
films i've ever seen creatively
and just the way it was shot and the
visual effects it was very very engaging
and very good
fenner
what would you say your favorite part of
rrr was um
spoiler alert
oh yeah spoiler alert not do not
when they dance not too naughty oh my
god oh wow oh it's just getting started
y'all it's immediate pain oh don't get
me
just like just like the emotions and our
are beautiful make you feel real pain
and
oh god okay yeah yeah so you feel real
pain when you're watching these
characters careful with the eyes when
you're watching these characters evolve
the relationship between the two of them
you can't help but feel baby because the
sticks
what were you talking about um it was
just it was so beautiful
you know my favorite part my favorite
part is when they climbed up
the light post and when he was on his
shoulders oh that was dope oh they
escaped from prison they brought the
callback of him being on his
oh honestly they were genuinely like the
moments in the film where they call back
to earlier parts where yeah
he's doing squads under the tree yeah no
he's got reasonable shoulders
ah
guys i'm gonna be honest
my soul's kind of filled with darkness
right now
i'd like to instead have you guys seen
lightyear
no
i've seen like
no no but i really want to i've heard
about a lot of people were upset because
it's not following
the storyline that they thought it
wouldn't be falling but they started
putting up
signs at the movie theater because
they're like you need to go not go
based off of the
movie
you okay
so i've seen it
christian and i actually went together
and
wait you both visually both want to see
it we both went to see it visually
stunning i mean we're talking
some of the most beautiful renders i've
ever seen in my life
really
really beautiful show to pixar shout out
to render man renderer and shout out
pixar studios you guys absolutely killed
it it's fantastic but story-wise it's
like
to me it's full of trope after trope
after trope things we've seen a million
times
don't start coming down jordan
your eyes are crying okay oh my soul is
crying right now okay let's be real not
good you said trophy it's very trophy
and like i was upset just how basic it
was because obviously pixar puts out
some amazing things like i really
enjoyed soul
soul was a great film to me it was very
i loved it yeah it moved me too
tears man like
and it was just so beautifully done and
there was so much care taken in it and
this just felt like uh
kind of a quick cash grab in a way yeah
man honestly that's disappointing it's
like
what was the quick cash story three was
light year
did you forget where i'm at
just rewind why do you think it was a
cash grab you don't think it was just
creative choice of a different storyline
that they wanted to tell i mean it just
it just we've seen everything that was
done in that movie
like if something is getting set up you
know it's going to pay off right away
there's no like
there's no and i i guess the reason i
bring it up is because to contrast with
rr there were so many things in rr that
i saw that i've never seen before in any
medium
and it was so beautiful and well done
and like engaging and exciting and new
to go from that to light year where it's
like okay this is hollywood's very basic
writing
you know
no one's talking to me what's the
promise
everyone's gone you just you just keep
talking you gotta
yeah so the thing
the thing with ror that
i really
enjoy this because
they took a lot of tropes you know a lot
of stuff that you have seen a million
times
and they just they made it they did it
at the be the top highest level yeah
yeah 100
everything that
everything that you see in that movie is
something that you've seen in other
movies in hollywood yeah you know
i just oh my god i'm gonna try not to
burp into the money dude
i'm sorry listeners
um
i
[Applause]
i feel like you can you can take a
simple idea a simple story of like
you know it's like a it's a revenge
story it's a love story in a way
it's um
it's a story about that we haven't seen
before i mean i i can't think of a
specific well you want to talk about
true friendship hollywood
that's true like friendship movies
yeah you know it genuinely the way i
tried to describe it to someone was it's
like if you took your favorite
corridor digital like action short where
it's just everything's amped up
and you just made it a three hour long
bromance yeah yeah in the best way
possible
yeah but it's like yeah it's like a
bromance and then it's also all these
other things there's so many movies that
it kind of
combines and in in a great way that like
you know it's like a
it's like a fusion restaurant yeah yeah
you have so many different uh genres and
stuff working together
in tandem and they're they work super
well together and like visual effects
wise um
yeah oh you want to get results
sometimes it looks incredible yeah yeah
i got lightheaded even when it falls
short of that it's still
they get the point across yeah they they
they do the vfx in a way that like
yeah it's not like what we can what we
see in something like life of pi right
you know with the photo reel but with
spiders some of the shots were like yeah
some of the tigers some of the animal
stuff works super well and it looks
incredible but it's just like in other
shots it's like doing a backflip and
carrying a guy and you're just like wow
what are physics
yeah it's almost like
the director
and vfx supervisors the producers the
people that are involved in the creative
on the show
are
going hey you know this doesn't look
photoreal but yeah and this maybe isn't
how tigers move but this is how we want
it to move to tell the story yeah and
that's the thing that you kind of learn
is and i think hollywood can kind of
take on is
the concepts are so wild and wacky that
the suspension of disbelief is kind of
built in
to the concept itself the ideas are so
wacky like a freaking
sitting on spoiler alert sitting on his
shoulders prison escape
is one of the coolest sequences i've
ever seen and it made no sense and it's
physically impossible
let me just lean into it because
it's fun to watch and they want to do it
they made it okay they made this world
where it was okay do you think
i don't know maybe this is my
nothing incredibly familiar
yeah careful on the ice thanks sean
evans
um not being super familiar with
bollywood or tollywood but do you think
rrr
hit so hard and is such kind of a
breakout hit in
north america and western cinema because
it's a little bit self-aware of what
it's doing do you guys think that um i
can see that i think it it i don't think
it is that i don't think it's like
self-aware it's take it's like serious
it's it's like it knows exactly what
it's trying to do and it knows like
this is a crazy action scene and it's
visual it's a visual spectacle yeah and
his idea of a visual spectacle is like
sometimes a little wacky yeah but it's
still like true to heart it has a heart
rate it's like anime anime is not trying
to be like it's not trying to be like oh
yeah we get it we're self-aware we're
just we're we're uh doing all these
weird visual quirks and weird stuff
right it's like they they
my brain is like half functioning right
i hear you because of how spicy they
didn't make mistakes because they said
they they set themselves up for for a
film like they
you know
i know what you're saying yeah and to me
to me what i love is that the visual
effects
on like even a prosumer level right and
what you can do at home has risen to a
point where
even
films like films from around the world
that maybe don't have the same budget
that like super blockbusters do
have like 80 the visual effects capacity
so these big big big ideas can still be
executed well or well enough to be
possible to kind of fit into the
suspension of disbelief and it's still
incredibly enjoyable there's like so bad
that it's good content
and this is it's almost there to being
oh this is this is really how quality
visual effects work but the concept is
there and that's like why i bring up
light year is you know again spoilers if
anyone hasn't seen light year now that
this is a spoiler because it's really
not but there's a moment where buzz is
falling
and the team extends a hand and catches
him as he falls right that trope we've
seen a hundred thousand times the arm
catch or are the things i've never seen
before and they did so many of them i'm
wondering you have the budget of a pixar
film and the artists that make this
stunning work why not put the time in
and develop a script that is
worth that you know what i mean and
that's where i get frustrated with
hollywood is the recycling of tropes
that have worked years years years and
years ago give us something new now
here's the one to one with that arm
catch thing in rrr they did an under the
bridge
which also is like important to the
dynamic of their relationship yeah
brother's body they play it up again
they do the fire the water they do it
under the water they're just dapping
each other yeah it's like we want to do
this cliche thing but how can we make it
like way cooler and different it becomes
like a visual motif and a theme you know
and it's like the same with the
shoulders thing yeah that's a wacky set
piece yeah kind of thing but it it is
also like
specifically showing how they are
bonding they're like brothers again you
know brothers reunited you know and the
same kind of um
feelings that they had for each other at
the top of the movie they now have
rekindled their yeah yeah you know
they're back they're stronger than ever
yeah you know it's powerful
and it means something and it's not just
we have to save buzz lightyear in a
certain kind of way right yeah you know
what's the best way to do that oh a
monkey chain yeah a monkey change
showing that we all have our place in
the team yeah i'm just trying to do a
call back with the monkey change i
didn't feel that way no because because
this technically took place before right
this is the movie that andy saw that
made him want the toy
and uh
for the monkey chain i don't think
anyone watching toy story is like i want
to see the monkey chase
we had kind of planned like hey maybe
let's watch it at the studio yeah and
freddie
freddie w fred amico they're like
shut up you stupid little humans yeah
that's how they refer to us
that we employ enjoy the cinematic
masterpiece in a theater with your loved
ones yeah and
holy crap
unlike anything else one of the best
theater going experience i've ever heard
people were standing and cheering the
whole time yeah well that's free
people walked out about three minutes in
which was awesome
they saw us all cheering and they were
like i don't know if we are ready to be
a part of it
okay i'm going to lightyear that's what
they said and they walked out yeah yeah
and that was jordan yeah jordan no i
wasn't yeah so i wasn't there at that
and i'm still bummed about it
and you guys run to the whole theater
right so pretty much the whole theater
except those two spots where those
people walk down yeah well matt dean
nick
and i i think that was everybody went to
go see it again or they went to go see
it again and i went to go see for the
first time and even then with just us
and everybody else in the theater was
people we didn't know still standing up
clapping still yeah whooping the entire
time laughing crying like it felt i went
to go see uh cult showing of the room
and tommy was there
and it's the most similar comparison i
can make is that it's like it's like a
really bonding experience to where at
the end the people in front of us were
turning around like laughing with us
what's that camaraderie like yeah in a
theater that you really can't get
anywhere else high five and from there
yeah yeah and you know outside of the
marvel cinematic universe when there's
like oh look who it is he showed up so
and so showed up we don't really have
that in yeah in my experience of
hollywood yeah
we can yeah like rrr is basically the
like
captain america picking up thor's hammer
moment but it's the entire
also though that was built up over
like 10 movies yeah right so of course
people are gonna be hyped at this point
because they've watched they put like
hours and hours into these characters we
only have three hours with these
characters and we're in after like the
first hour we're like we're on board
honestly and cheering and like on the
stage
and they kept surprising us yeah
back-to-back they've even let us hold on
to like suspension for that long which i
really the fact that there's an
intermission and i was like wow that's
the end of the movie that's beautiful
and it's like intermission oh it's like
your happy house yeah and it was got
better by the way intermissions in
three-hour movies should be in every
three-hour movie oh yeah it lets you
chew on what you've seen it lets you go
we and chew on some food too and chew on
some food
why does every move you want to be three
hours long now yeah you want to go in
for he wants to go back
we're going where are you our first
myself i don't want to do this i really
don't you literally signed up to the
whole stretch i did i needed
drinking right here
it's a team christian dean
do you want to dance
[Laughter]
yeah all right guys are we doing it
again yeah we have cause
are you guys doing it look at this bite
this is this was my bite this was yeah i
took a big truck
it looks pathetic but i took a big chunk
off the end that was skinnier i didn't
do a big bite look at how much i have
left why are we doing this
okay that's a very good question
three two one
that was so much pain and it's about to
be oh oh oh my body doesn't like it my
ears is literally ringing another right
theater going experience
that we experienced recently
top gun maverick oh my gosh so good i
absolutely loved it no absolutely
incredible and i've never done this in a
movie oh dude yeah i did this four times
i was
like sincerely i did this like wow edge
of my seat the whole time
i have never fist bumped someone more
watching yeah me and john were side by
side we're just like fishing them in the
hall and the whole time yeah everybody's
so hyped it's just like is it is it true
that that whole thing was shot in the
cockpit
a whole bunch of those stay with me
buddy
stay with me how are you doing you seem
like you're doing just fine
on the uh uh the ringer podcast your
shout out the big picture shout out sean
fantasy okay you need to shout out lots
of straws shout out sean evans
director
they shot
in the cockpit
and it sounded amazing they like custom
built out
oh jordan is actually dying actually
like the sensors of the cameras they
took the whole camera bodies apart i
think they partnered with sony to build
custom cameras oh that's cool
yeah that where you could basically have
the sensor like
wired through a new different part of
the car
to like the lens it was like just wires
oh yeah no way so they the the actors
actually had to hit their own record
yeah actually had to
record they were in the front of the
plane and the pilot was behind like how
we shoot some stuff sometimes if we go
if we have rigs they're just like yeah
you just hit record yeah it's crazy my
tongue hurts
anyway
and they had to like invent stuff for
that movie and i love that now tom
cruise can actually fly i understand
yeah because he's a madman yeah how i
mean they had to invent camera systems
that can follow jets
but he wasn't flying i mean was he
flying in any of that or was he always
being piloted uh i think they probably
already always had a safety pilot with
him yeah but i think he was actually
flying some in some of the shots yeah
but most of the other actors
they're not actually flying oh god it
actually just like creeps up on you a
little bit yeah one of the uh one of the
stories that i heard from that
said is that the guy who passed out
actually passed out oh wow is that true
i don't know if that's true that could
be totally false but my mouth's too hot
to care
did you you know you pass out i did
all he did was set a wink emoji
he sent you a wink emoji when you asked
him
oh he actually passed out that sounds
like he's
that sounds like it could go either way
it sounds like yeah
i could ask i could ask
yeah
it's hurt so much
this the second one creeps up on you
like the first one hits you super hard i
cried remember the second bite you kind
of it's like oh i'm accustomed to this
it's like jumping yeah yeah cold water
false confidence oh
it's uh um
when you were talking to me and saying
oh i think are you past the threshold i
really didn't feel any additional yeah
pain me neither what but now it has
it's gotten exponentially worse than it
was to where it's in parts of my mouth
that i didn't know i had yeah you know
what i mean i feel it on my gums
everything's numb everything is numb but
also on fire and i feel it yeah i feel
like i might throw up
you have to throw a bucket right there
you do have the throat don't throw up on
the mic
um ew jordan uh that's the beer i think
that's not helping anybody but yeah no
genuinely um
i don't want to blow my nose because
it'll blow all the powders maverick was
incredible i love that it kind of just
became a mission possible movie at the
end too yeah
a tom cruise starring or
top gun
a tom cruise movie you know i mean like
i was always tom cruise did he sprint
and he did right oh in the in the
football scene dude this is awesome
this is going to be spoiler yeah
when the heats on the spoilers come out
it's just
super sick
spoiler alert the movie is dope
and funded by the us military
that makes a lot of sense and i didn't
see the original if you're opposed to
that um i've never seen the original
top gun
i've never seen the original and i
thought i'd need to before seeing this
but seeing this was a last minute kind
of idea
let's listen to a podcast and there's
someone i watched the original hated the
original went to go watch the new one
and they loved the new one so that being
said you don't need to watch the the
first one
good i'm sorry the first top gun is not
a good movie it's very 80s it's so weird
and
the story doesn't make it too campy
it's like barely a plot
yeah it's um
i do love that they use that
music
at the beginning of the new one that 80s
music got me so in the vibe immediately
new shopkin is just fun does anyone get
pass out vibes
my ears are ringing
i get hallucinogenic vibes for sure yeah
it at this point does feel a little bit
like a like a drug
not in a good way though
like a bad feel like i'm having a bad
trip
not that i would know what that's like
yeah mom and dad exactly with that just
kidding by the way we're only
18 minutes
away really it feels like an eternity
it's gonna be only 18 minutes the
shortest castle
i don't want to be
well i know speaking of movies too i
mean because you literally can't think
of any other topic because my brain is
fried
but
i know i'm super late on the late train
here but everything everywhere all at
once
i just saw that maybe a week and a half
ago also great and it is one of my
favorite films i've ever seen
absolutely spectacular the daniels
mucho respecto yeah absolutely and this
is again a great example of seeing
things you haven't seen before right
that's all i want when i when i escape
my reality i want to escape to something
new maybe this is just me i i'm totally
okay with this just be me but
they took me somewhere new and it was
exciting and it was interesting and it
was so well
it made me inspired as a creator to want
to get to that level of like yes can i
come up with something so different
genius didn't you like work on it or
something
jordan no i didn't i didn't uh directly
work on it but
uh before working here at corridor
um i was like that was something that
that came up that i could have possibly
worked on um but i didn't uh
for various reasons
and now i'm here eating helen ray so i
really screwed up there
but i made bad life decisions that
brought you to this moment the small
team that they had that worked on it did
an absolutely stellar job it was like
what
seven yeah it was just a few of them and
and i'm so impressed by the quality of
it too and yeah it's like just a few
yeah there's just a few of them and they
absolutely slide it and you know i it's
one of the films that i watch and i i
have tremendous respect for film
directors i've only cut one feature film
in my life for my friend
you edited it i edited it yeah because
initially i was i wanted to be an editor
when i first started out and my friend
trevor stevens was up trevor uh he made
his first film rock steady row okay and
i i edited that feature film
and seeing the process creatively of
having to maintain a vision throughout
the course of a film and i'm coming from
directing commercial content primarily
i have so much respect for people who
can maintain
their vision through all of that let
alone if they're also getting network
notes or uh you know notes from
producers that are trying to step on
their vision if they can see it through
that and deliver something at the end
like not start sharing away not start
stringing or losing the like i was
losing the plot editing it going is this
good like is this what it's supposed to
be and trevor absolutely nailed it all
the way through to where i said
i don't have the capacity to be a film
director that's what i learned i don't
have the consistency of vision for
something that long and the daniels
in everything everywhere all at once is
the title
yeah you're gonna get it here you're
gonna get it there nearly did it
everywhere at once near the end of the
film i remember thinking
this is this is why i don't think i can
be a film director because they nailed
it it was so good everything was so
thought out it was such a beautiful
thing that's my biggest goal in life is
to direct a feature film oh no way i
didn't know that yep i don't wanna i
can't edit or do visual effects like you
studs
thank you for the like pat but
i believe that to you guys but i'm
direct no wait what kind of movie would
you make
that's the thing i want to make every
kind
like i don't like rrr
yeah just make armor
something else oh yeah our reaction we
just didn't do effects artists react
check it out yes just dropped yes react
to our with freddie w that's kind of why
we brought it up well that's not really
right right but it's also
yeah that's that's a react with freddie
yeah freddy was in the theater when we
watched it the first time freddie's
watched it five times he was he was
going nuts in the theater and this is
probably the third or fourth time he
watched his fourth time watching five
seven
he was going nuts and i don't blame him
i watched it last night on netflix
in a different language right yeah it's
not good it's not as good as they're
totally right you gotta watch it in the
original language guys if it's still in
theaters when you're seeing this please
do me a favor and book a ticket
immediately it's just so like theaters
though it's in like your little
yeah artsy party theater what i was
saying is the director
feel like has some influence from
tarantino
yes he has
who does who the director of this movie
which also by the way fun fact i didn't
know this until i looked it up like last
night this guy also directed something
that we've reacted to on a bollywood
react oh no the fly
they did they did this movie the fl i
think it's called the fly uh-huh um
which is about this guy who gets turned
into a fly by some magical means
the one with um
not the not the face rippy he turns into
a little just yeah you guys know
immediately i was talking about yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he directed this movie called the
fly where this
guy is
turned into a fly and then fights as a
fly yeah which
there's action scenes
with a man and a fly
you have to figure out how to kill
people as a is it like like ant-man
is it more entertaining
is is it more entertaining than the fly
episode of breaking bad i was going to
ask what's with this fly thing no the
the the boys directors love flies the
new season you heard about the boys
no that's a spoiler yeah and since i
haven't seen it we can't go there yeah
we can spoil
other people but don't spoil things for
us let me just say this about the boys
if anyone hasn't seen the boys
the
gore the gore vfx oh or the best i've
ever seen top notch and i love gory
effects i i just i enjoy them immensely
so good because i must be a broken
person but i just think they're so cool
shout out jordan allen's childhood
the whale stuff that they did which a
lot of it was directly oh man so good
but season three has upped the ante and
i'm not gonna say anything about it but
don't say it but the the violence in
that is
just they have crossed the threshold
into just totally real realism total
realism and it's fantastic it's i'm so
so impressed by the quality of that work
i have the chill check out the first
episode of that i know what i'm warming
up
no dude i'm not doing another one you
you did you were the one that was like
oh we're not gonna eat the whole one no
i don't think we'll get through the
whole thing if you look at how much is
left look at this there's too much
there's so much
i feel bad
but but when i in gattaca where he's
like they swim out spoilers for gattaca
if y'all haven't checked out canada yet
they slim out and he's like i never
saved anything for the swim back that's
you right now dude
oh yeah there's a hundred percent this
is candy yeah you ready i can't do it
you were hating on me you're drowning um
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna take it
from the south side
i'm gonna take it from the back that's
what she said
that is what she's at
how are you doing this
oh
no it was so close
i feel like i i have cooked no i'm a
little bit worried when i throw up
christian do you have other one
christian how are you doing
oh no christian took a third bite too
did you actually yeah
i was going i can't do it man i can't do
it
we maybe we shouldn't applaud chaos
what we should we shouldn't
what are you talking about uh matt
what are you working matt what are you
working on this week dude
dude yeah matt what are you working on
oh you know what i was gonna oh god i
don't know i have the storm still i
don't feel it look i'm in the eye of the
storm right now there's don't nobody
like you have nothing you're numb from
the last fight so like when you take
another one you don't feel it right away
and then it just like you'll feel it
i don't want to do it but i will throw
up don't you don't need to don't do
pressure i don't want you to throw up
but i want to prefer
you are perfect just the way you are
okay jordan however you never talk about
me like that it's interesting
so okay
so what do you have to do what you're
thinking of the question
yes we're this is a normal podcast i
don't even ask and answer questions
yeah right what are you doing speaking
of that question that you just asked um
when we were talking about feature films
you were saying how you can like kind of
lose track of what's going on even in
what i'm doing right now which is just
like it's just four episodes of a show
called punch for punch we're working on
uh for netflix thanks definitely netflix
spoiler alert
um
that is still it's still like we need to
keep a uniform style and make sure it
all flows and you know going through
something that becomes like an hour and
20 worth of
a show yeah you know it does become like
it's a lot to think about because you
have to think about how it's all gonna
match visually um how they how each
episode flows together how it all rides
out um
and yet it's youtube still so you know
people maybe won't watch them in order
uh but for the ones that will i
definitely want to keep that in mind we
all do we're all kind of considering
this especially considering if it does
get on the netflix platform yeah yeah
that'd be so cool is that like i mean i
feel like that's a dumb question but is
that your ultimate goal
oh for sure i mean all of yeah
definitely it's our goal is like you
know if they want to if they want to put
it on their our goal isn't even
delivering what we have
yeah the first platform but i said this
before but it
so feels like a real show it just gives
me such that's like mythbusters vibes
i love it when you say that keep saying
that you know it's like if comedian
getting caught getting coffee and get in
the car
drinking coffee if that's you know
that's on netflix and i feel like this
is yeah this could easily be
like i don't feel like i feel pain
anymore it got on my lip dude
the longest was i feel like i just got
like injections or
something dude federer is
better you're gone man
you're in another dimension right now
enter the ghost realm
i'm in
i'm in canada
i'd love to have him back in his natural
habitat oh my god he would love it too
speaking of mythbusters
i think it's out now right like
wait what you're at that challenge with
uh yeah the effects were practical yeah
kind of yeah i say
uh punch for punch reminds me of
mythbusters and that is a high
compliment because mythbusters it's one
of my favorite shows of all time adam
savage jamie heinemann tory grant
they're just
i know um anyways
adam savage is incredible and we have
done a collaboration with him and tested
um
the crew drove up to san francisco
and uh got to tour his his warehouse had
tested
and while they were up there they filmed
a uh a challenge um
with adam savage from the movie
chinatown
take your time which is basically uh it
boils down to a practical versus vfx
what is better
what is worse yeah
and it's is it some is does the answer
lie somewhere in between
perhaps yeah check it out but anyways it
boiled down to they shot uh this effect
practically there's this amazing
practical stunt where they
slice uh jack knuckleson's nose open
with the switchblade and it looks
amazing in the practical movie
um
and
they also while they're up there ran
nico they filmed a clean plate with adam
and
then
we're like hey fenner
you got a couple hours
you have to do it with vfx the challenge
adam and it was awesome and so anyways
he did it we had a time crunch and i
mean i i haven't even seen the final cut
of the video but uh what you did looks
great yeah it looks really happy with
how it turned out given the time yeah um
the practical looks amazing i was happy
with where the vfx got to and adam was
super stoked on it i was we got to have
a little video called him and he's just
the nicest coolest dude and
it's a
i guess there's like the classic
expression i've never met your heroes
but i was like yeah man it's a harley's
worth meeting yeah hero worth meeting
and
such
a kind accommodating awesome dude he's
such a cool
to be around you guys you can tell he
loves it you can see the passion it's so
great and inspiring i mean that feels
like it has shout out adam savage yeah
it feels like it has
real legs to be a series too the vfx
first practical because
it's there's still a lot of confusion
over the separation of special effects
and visual effects in the industry the
third one
that's just dying i took another bite
while you were talking about the fourth
i did
sorry it's become not ceremonious i'm
just gonna keep good you guys but until
it's gone because i said it at the top
of the podcast i'm going to finish this
damn i'm going to finish this damn thing
okay i didn't know you're going to go
talk to daughters now i don't want to
play it when i make a commitment
i'm just showing the camera how much
more if you commit to the bit you gotta
commit all the way oh you're dead you're
dead inside no one said anything about
that first of all we were supposed to
get one tinder and and split that one
do you say tinder tender
take another bite you won't do it
chicken tendy i just took another bite
while you were talking yeah i did
earlier oh my gosh you're broken inside
i can't do this why are you doing this
matt's dead dude because i'm dead inside
oh my god you're going to live on the
toilet and i will not be there to hold
your i'm going to yoga like i feel like
it does get grosser and grosser isn't it
yeah
like
well i don't think our buddies are
really meant to be like poisoned it's no
there's a reason they give you gloves to
hold them
right
it's more so maybe it's curing like
things wrong in our body it's just like
burning
all the good bacteria
but anyways we're not here to talk about
spice yeah because we're talking about
about filmmaking so yeah so that would
be going around and saying what would
you get up to coleman what you up to
what'd you up to well sorry no real
quick did you finish the adam sandwich
uh yeah check out the video
did you do a spoiler we didn't say if
that was a spoiler alert i don't i don't
think we really supposed to yeah the
video
check it out check out quarter quarter
crew
tested youtube and quarter digital.com
okay can you say cordary one more time
corridor
corner
corridor digital
jordan jordan what are you working on
what's going
uh this week is a uh it's a slow week
production wise
um i can talk now that's cool
um yeah we're prepping it's a lot of
prep and you know we have if you're a
website user you understand that we've
been having some issues with our website
lately but we're also trying to make it
better more functional a better layout
you know when it comes to the series in
the season so i've been oh finner's
going for it winners doing it
i've been i've been doing the website
stuff a lot of website stuff but we're
also
prepping for the next punch for punch uh
that's right episode which is gonna be
spoiler alert uh stranger things
and we're doing a whole set deck in our
studio we're literally
building a whole rigging machine you
know it's just a spoiler alert for
something that's not even released yet
yes
this is the biggest spoiler podcast
we've
our last episode of punch for punch
we're filming it next week yeah and it's
going to be a really fun one with a lot
of fun little stunts and yeah stranger
things we're going all out fun little
practical stunt we're gonna do i would
love to react to the short of that that
would be very cool oh it wasn't great
i'll react the inside of my body is in
so much pain yeah i feel like in my
throat now i'm gonna stop eating it is
anyone's stomach twisting yeah no i i
seriously feel like i'm gonna throw up
not like a but i'm not we're not here to
talk about that i'm here to talk about
stranger things
have you guys seen all of the first part
of season 23
anyways i thought it was incredible
i think it returned to form for the show
uh it maybe to me is the best season
since the first season yeah even better
than the first season
in hindsight like the first season it's
very good but it's so small in scope
and season four is incredible
tremendous horror
there's so many amazing visuals i
absolutely love the um
spoiler alert
the ragdoll stuff where it's just like
hey let's just frickin
exorcist bone break
i'll say this about that the first one
they did spoiler alert in the trailer
with the girl yeah was the best one that
was stellar the other ones were a little
bit lacking like you could see oh no i
don't know if it was the time they had
to do it but the first one was so good
every time
what i will say is the decision to make
it way darker and gorier and more
violent
i personally love it because it's great
think about how terrifying the uh
underneath what's it called the
undergrowth the underground now the
upside underground upside down
the undergrowth is
it's like it's absolutely terrifying and
it makes sense that it would be this
horrific and it feels a lot more like a
horror series now than it did before so
you see all the practical
oh my god the video of uh i haven't seen
the venka practical makeup the the main
monster spoiler alert
it's all practical well it looks
incredible all the stuff in the upside
down just like it's just like a my own
worth of props not the moving
parts of his neck though no that's not
practical yeah i was going to say let's
see what they enhance it it's just like
the conclusion we come to do with adam
savage
that's the best of both worlds
the best visual effects is that on top
of special effects i totally agree
say that again
harry potter
i remember peter
yeah i was so good that reminded me of
the stranger
i'm not joking i think i'm high that's
why i keep going in and out of
consciousness i feel like i could pass
out or fall asleep you know i always
understood why hot ones were so
successful but now i truly feel like i
understand you know yeah
should we we should
don't do that sean evans has to do that
every like week or more
but but
there's different spices and flavors
it's not like you're on the same one
and i'm curious what is the heat of
howland
christian can you look that up jamie can
you look at the scallions what is it the
scale scoville let's go let's go
oh
[Music]
and now for some context y'all christian
has done the hot ones challenge
so he knows exactly what this feels like
and so he knows that this what we're
experiencing right now is the pinnacle
of the hot ones challenge this is what
happens when you work with a bunch of
men
this is worse than the ones
yeah how did i get ripped into this i
don't know
guys we're not here to talk about
spiders talk about spice we're not here
to talk about spikes
jordan allen what are you up to this
week buddy i'm working on the witcher
short some visual effects for that which
are super fun spoiler alert
can i spoil her
henry cavill okay can i spoiler alert
the details of the short oh yeah and
henry cavill approved can i like talk
about the ring and stuff did you really
no
all right spoiler alert talk about that
there's a ring but i'm moving on
there's a water that's really cool
actually fenner did a really cool shot
uh for the one or where
a sword goes through the back of a
dude's head
and uh yeah it's a sword goes through
the back of his head and he also pulls a
sword up through the ground through a
guy's neck you could also say
i feel like we should not spoil this
don't spoil it so that and that's all
that happens
that's everything that happens and
and all that actually didn't happen
because i'm making it up because i'm not
real spice what but we're not here to
talk about the place must flow but we're
not here to talk about no it was real it
was really well looking at all y'all
screens right now because you know we
were all there on location watching them
shoot and
i think that's why it took so long is
figuring out these gags and how to do it
practically first or like knowing chris
knowing where and how to shoot this oner
so that we could do all of the stuff in
post for you guys and then seeing you
guys do it yeah we were saying today
like
this way the thing is shot is awesome
like it just looks good yeah even
without that and chris he definitely
took his time because it took us two
days we had to go back to that location
to do it but then two seven days i
didn't know that yeah he's going to be
stoked to hear you guys
so
chris cowan you probably know him from
uh stuntman reaction shout out chris
chris he's a stunt director who's worked
on many things like some of the marvel
movies
[Music]
um
he does he's like known for his wonders
um and these are like sequences where
it's either is the illusion of one take
that's flowing
um or
a proper one or where the camera is just
moving for an extended period of time
around you for him it's usually action
because he's an action director um so he
came on board for the witcher episode um
and shot a a fight sequence for us and
that's also because he'd worked on the
witcher and
and he also yes he also made uh a fight
sequence in the witcher yeah which goes
hand in hand
he didn't do the warner in the witcher
no he didn't do no but he did but he did
he did another he's an action director
he doesn't just do wonders yeah and
spoiler alert the warner and the witcher
season one is very cool yeah it's so
it's a really really cool dynamic fight
sequence if you guys haven't seen that
check it out
is amazing and i kind of want to
re-watch it i feel like a lot of people
have dunked on the witcher and i don't
know why i really enjoyed it
it was enjoyable and did you play the
game
uh it's it's my current in-progress game
it's too long how long has it been in
progress
like three years three years
it's it's men it's one of those games
that i just i absolutely love it
but i'm just stuck in the side quest
trap where i'm just like oh i'm only 13
percent of the way through the story
yeah
what kind of game is this is this like
escape from tarkov it's like open world
world
like
is that exciting
what is escape from tarkov
okay it's not at all like that because
you
know
you heard this you heard about this
have you heard have you seen this one
i've
and you just walk around doing quests
and stuff see that's the type of game i
would like i i don't care for the battle
royale games yeah that i would enjoy
single player it's all story it's
incredible stop okay um bastard how did
you do that jordan
um you guys are
worrying speaking of open world games my
stomach is screaming speaking of open
world games i wish we would have got a
regular tinder i'm really excited for
star field i bought the hype oh my gosh
star field yes that's the microsoft
conference we're talking about video
games here yeah this is kind of where i
check it out sorry i'm gonna check you
back in we'll show you back there we'll
show you back
starfield looks absolutely insane i know
you should get hyped for video games
anymore especially a year early trash
i do mass effect don't preorder
basically i mean i can't i can't get
hyped for video games yeah especially
from bethesda personally afterwards
sorry no 76 was upsetting to me so many
games battle the new battlefield is just
now starting to get decent with one map
that they released dude halo infinite
it's like came out and it was just like
oops we dropped it
and it's like at the same time they're
like in their other hand they're like
oops we dropped it because we're holding
our baby i saw and any of the show it
was i saw half of an article while
scrolling so you know it's true that the
dlc for that isn't coming out until 2025
at the soonest the for halo no it's like
they have like they have
like downloadable they laid out like a
road plan also known as like
stuff that should be in there at launch
like forge mode which was like in halo 3
which was like yeah that's upsetting
so barebones they're like oops not ready
and i'm like it's the longest
development cycle on a halo game ever
and it's
it sucks because i love halo it's my
favorite franchise it's just like i love
the campaign the campaign was awesome
yeah and the multiplayer is good too
it's just good but it's just like not
there's not enough stuff yeah there's
not enough stuff it's like you need to
have a forge mode yeah it's like a weird
battle pass grind and it's like if they
had just done it
classically they caught with a halo tv
show on my channel they did yeah
which is i would say
well i would say this spoiled my
personal opinion
it's
not
great
okay
okay your stomach's announced christian
yeah no it's here to talk about i think
the general consensus of the halo tv
show is that it's like an okay sci-fi
show and it's not even a halo is the
storyline horrible it's
bad characters it's not at all halo like
jordan would like to completely wrote
out master cheeks yeah you get to see uh
the whole thing the main character halo
is master chief the whole thing through
all the games everything why do i like
it he's always wearing this you get to
see those master cheeks he literally has
to see the master cheeks he's on
functions
both jordans would like it yeah okay
it's just uh it's um
it's like completely a different story
completely different character it's
really shot well you know because i you
know i can't say this i can take like a
bad story if it's like shot and directed
it doesn't look like it the stuff you
showed me use the stuff you showed me
that's like uh band of brother style
christmas
oh okay so i was showing jordan as a
in one of my darkest hours
um
when i was very sad about the paramount
show
i was showing
jalan the uh halo landfall how was their
short film and was there but just you
knew i needed representation that's as
much as possible yeah it was intentional
austin the spice uh directed by neil
blomkamp who did like district nine
elysium uh and it's incredible it's like
a short film and it feels like gritty it
feels like band of brothers it's very
well done and the tv show in my opinion
just feels like a generic like
sci-fi channel like yeah rip-off thing
the budget yeah they did though
they had the same
have you heard of this little indie
anything called the mandalorian they
have the same budget and it wow you know
what i'm so sick of simulation
these people are getting these huge
budgets and then they are just like i
don't know where the money is going yeah
it's like the story's not there the
directing isn't good like the like even
like lighting continuity isn't there
like there's a lot
on that show off the top of your head
what was the budget for rrr i feel like
you'd know this
i saw what the budget was it was
like was it insane like crazy high i'm
curious oh what do you think 40 50
million no i don't even hire no it's
it's a joke how much could it cost i
think they got i think they had 60 mail
for that it's more than 60 million
for what for what
oh that's but jordan 5.5 billion is not
usd
okay whatever
that's close so a lot of people are
doing this all dramatically
well i was trying to bring it for a full
circle you thought it was 5.5 billion
didn't you um i don't know
i'm sorry for the spectacle of that
movie and for how long it was that's
like really very efficient with their
budget yeah yeah they maximized yeah
these little netflix shows are not
getting it well yeah it just it's
i feel like we've
i feel like everyone
like no one asked for this version of
the halo tv show like it was originally
supposed to be a halo movie i believe
that was going to be neil blomkamp and
peter jackson together
really yeah
oh whoa yeah peter jackson yeah um
like what a workshop was doing all like
the practical effects and stuff for it
yeah i didn't know you guys they not me
not me this is beautiful practical
what a what a um what a workshop is like
known for the practical thing it's very
talented like lord of the rings all the
orcs and stuff that's all practical oh
it's almost like fractured they have
some of their work at the is it the
academy museum in l.a yeah yeah they
have some stuff from the film it's
really cool also just
the sidebar super tangy have you guys
seen the stills from the new amazon
series the practical orcs uh no i have
not they look so good really i've not
seen this oh but anyways going back to
it so neil blomkamp and um peter jackson
were originally going to do halo and
they did landfall
and i guess the project just kind of
fell apart microsoft was like oh no it
just it never happened
and so it fell apart
and then spielberg came on board to do
it yeah
also would have been amazing yeah and
then that fell through and then it
became a paramount plush show that's not
great imagine master chief lost on an
alien planet and he says master chief
phone home that's how great that would
be basically
[Laughter]
also i'm gonna have to say this right
now the neo bomb camp one would have
worked i don't think the spielberg one
would have been me neither i think
silver would have tackled halo imagine
like uh ready player one yeah halo well
yeah and that's what's in ready player
one like there's literally stars and
stuff show up dude i hate that movie
yeah
it's not good
you hate ready player one yeah great
okay is that a show
let me tell you all
i can't phrase it though
but one of my favorite like little
film easter eggs that pops up every now
and then every time a new bombcat movie
comes out is spot the halo prop where
like yeah oh that's fine uh elysium
there's just this random i guess he's
like a mercenary and he's just started
wearing a halo marine helmet where
you're like oh that's oh they're just
re-using props yeah but oh my god jordan
yeah it's um
yeah jordan going back to your goal of
directing your own film i have this
personal vendetta of i would love to
direct my own halo
really
yeah and just because i think it's cool
yeah i just love it to do it someone's
gotta do it right yeah you can do not
that i know i could but it's like i just
at least you could do it i just wouldn't
have them like get naked and bang an
alien absolutely obviously we need that
yeah
don't knock until you try it
i've gotta have those master cheats baby
i think it's just being married to
something
yeah for a certain amount of time and
then you get to get a divorce it's like
bye-bye yeah yeah you know that's what
directed it hurts me it hurts you said
something interesting about like what
the director's like
what his spin was on that
the whole like angle of the chief
character
being that like he wanted to
make him more human oh yeah but like the
more compelling version of that would
definitely have been how does he deal
with being a human but growing up as
this like manufactured
machine man you know
how do you deal with the humanity yeah
and they start to sort of explore that
storyline and handle four and it's like
really well done and you're like whoa
okay like how does he like reconcile
with being like
okay i know i'm a human but i like can't
relate to anyone around me and like
everyone i've loved is just slowly dying
off yeah and it's so well done and then
the paramount show you just end up with
like
not that
not that at all no yeah it's i don't
know it's
i feel like this last few years has been
a lot of
do what you want very cool oh my god
dude i just took another bite did you
actually
we can address the spice thank god
they're dying it's so sweet addressing
the spice the whole time that was
absolutely ridiculous i don't think i
can do anymore i wouldn't i don't
how is it legal
this is my question how is this legal
it touches my lips my lips are they feel
like they're burning off
it doesn't taste good it tastes like
chemicals hungry chicken is good you
taste the chicken the flavor of the
spice is just horrendous i only did two
bites my stomach is tight enough to do
like a medium plus at a at highlands
he's so good yeah don't get me wrong
this chicken is usually good but at this
spice level it just doesn't taste like
good it doesn't taste like anything but
pain we all cried yeah that's the thing
is the medium plus
medium and medium plus are the two best
chicken sandwiches i've ever had in my
life i love them i adore them they're
fantastic it's your
it doesn't make sense are you doing a
bite for the what are you doing i'm fine
you're finishing it you're you're mania
matt wins i don't even care that should
be just the thumbnail
griffin just so you know i am high right
now yeah we're already floating
on clouds i didn't know existed i don't
think i can do it yeah yeah are you
serious hold it no you can finish it i'm
so close it's one more bite matt we keep
talking about how this was here
yeah yeah so again my whole thing is it
doesn't really make sense that this is a
valid choice i get it for a challenge
but if anyone out there has done this
just for the pleasure and hasn't
documented it just did it and enjoyed
the experience and we'll do it again
please comment because i want to know
that you exist because i don't believe
it um i i if you did make a video
oh yeah because i want to see that let's
not share this pain together so much how
are you doing i don't want to this is
truly a spicy thing how is your mouth
okay
there get in there look this holds both
of us you'll love it i can't i can't all
right so i gotta stop oh yeah don't hurt
yourself sit right here buddy i gotta
stop y'all smell like i'm sorry oh yeah
keep that sure maybe one of you was
rooting for me to finish it
oh my god all right let's hurry oh 10
minutes all right then i gotta make it
take a nice healthy bite there yeah
there you go buddy oh my god can we
answer a serious question about uh
dungeon drugs
it's not that bad right now griffin how
have you been enjoying working on son of
a dungeon season two i really like the
new uh
yeah i really like the new art style
you've developed it's very like
hellboy-esque almost right
yeah mom
i thought you said it wasn't that bad
griffin it's not we're not talking about
the spice though yeah no but son of a
dungeon season two
this isn't
that
wow
you know it's a funny you mentioned oh
boy
i've been really inspired by mike manola
and frank miller and
uh people in the comments been
mentioning darkest dungeon
that's what those are my picking
it just makes my mouth really numb but
i'm drawing take your time
the crew cuts is really well i'm only
halfway through it but the fact that
you're using like models and because
you've pulled me away from my desk a few
times yeah i tell you to pull jordan
away and then you you create your
drawings based off of that did who did
you learn that from
you're supposed to do that man
that's like
that's like art school 101 like it's
always good to work
from either life
or from photo reference yeah
because you're
so you're not gonna do good man
god you're not gonna do it
[Laughter]
i told you we just ate the poison it's
gonna you have more characters this year
by a large margin
and i gotta say that the new style that
you're doing like friggin amazing right
i appreciate it it's so
characters cool season to 40 characters
expensive that's a little longer is it
harder to draw in this new style
time-wise than it was
simply more cartoonish
yes and no
it's um
ready to repeat the question
it's both easier and harder in different
ways uh i've
really simplified like i added way too
many steps to my workflow
in an effort to be more organized but i
actually was like adding a lot of
unnecessary steps so i undid that this
time
but also in this new style like there's
some parts about it that are just
fundamentally harder
to draw like all the really intense
shadows like
it looks simple because like three
quarters of the drawing is just colored
in black but like
if you don't do it right it just looks
really bad and like you don't know what
you're doing
so it
it's hard it's hard but it's cool yeah
it's very rewarding and i it's nice to
hear that people are enjoying them
because uh yeah i was nervous for a bit
i was nervous about being able to pull
it off
yeah man it looks really incredible like
thank you i feel like the new son of a
dungeon season
has upped the ante in every way yeah and
that's what you would love to see the
arts your eyes the art style the stuff
you're right
it's so nice thank you dude the the the
cg shots the vfx shots the editing the
mograph i feel like this season is a a
big step up which is crazy because
season one was already super cool dude
yeah do you find yourself to be your
biggest critic when it comes to your
stuff because
everyone here thinks it's amazing were
you nervous that we wouldn't think it
was good or something what do you mean
when you say you were nervous that's
like what's happening on the island it's
like podcast
he's going to answer your favorite
colors oh my god no that is a good uh
that's a good question because i feel
like my teeth hurt like
like like literally each individual
tooth hurts but also
i feel like i am
probably harder on myself than other
people are on me because like
i'm not like by a long shot of the best
illustrator but i feel like so often i
get just like paralyzed by like imposter
syndrome that it gets really hard to
make things and i struggled with that
for a long time until son of a dungeon
when i realized
the only way to get through that is just
to literally
just do it even if it's not going to be
good like if it's not good just do
another one
and do you find that when you look back
on your past work you're more impressed
with it than you are in the moment
because i noticed that sometimes with my
past few effects or i'm super hard on
myself and then after time goes by like
not gonna go oh that was actually pretty
good yeah i've definitely had that as
well
i will i will piggyback on that and say
that
everything i've done where i tried
really really hard to do a good job i
look back on and i'm like yeah it's not
that good but everything that i had fun
making
are the ones that i like more in
hindsight you could always show through
shows through when you have fun and
enjoy what you're doing absolutely yeah
it always always does and it's more
worthwhile it's more worthwhile yeah
wisdom right there some hot wisdom
spicy whiskey spicy
what's been your favorite drawing so far
in the season
spoilers
i think either uh jake's character
warren
uh
ren's character bob
or
there is another character who's like a
priestess who i just really like the way
the shadow and the costume and the props
and like it all just came together in a
way where i was like man
i [ __ ] draw stuff dude yeah
you know that's a good feeling we need a
t-shirt with just all of this
oh that'd be cool
and it says i [ __ ] draw stuff dude
all right i think we need to start
cueing for the bathroom yeah griffin
you're going to have to take the picture
you're gonna have to take these
thumbnail pics quick oh yeah we're gonna
i'm gonna yeah all right all right i'm
about to go into a couch
[Music]
let us know if you guys want us to do
the spice cast again with new cast
members definitely holidays yeah
never doing that that wasn't me that was
spinner all right bathroom
recommended thanks for doing the other
videos